vean la manera en que estos dos
capacitores de save arts y tres caras
están conectados qué va a pasar si los
conectamos a una batería de 8 volts pues
como en todos los capacitores se van a
separar las cargas las cargas negativas
se van a separar del lado derecho de
estos capacitores y van a dirigirse
hacia la terminal positiva de la batería
pero cuando llegan al otro lado sucede
algo interesante las cargas llegan a
esta bifurcación y ahora tienen una
opción para decidir hacia donde
continúan ya sea al lado positivo del
capacitor de 3 paradas o al lado
positivo del capacitor de 6 para cada
uno de los capacitores va a obtener algo
de la carga pero ya que el capacitor de
6 jarabes tiene el doble de capacitancia
de la que tiene el capacitor de tres
caras el capacitador de 6 baratas va a
tener el doble de carga que el de tres
faros así que el doble de cargas
negativas van a ser separados del lado
derecho del capacitor de 6 farts
el doble de cargas negativas van a ser
depositados en la terminal izquierda de
este mismo capacitor sabemos que el
capacitor de 6 france va a tener el
doble de carga pero que tanta carga van
a tener estos capacitores aun cuando el
circuito lúcio un poco complicado en
este caso encontrar la carga es bastante
sencillo y la razón de que sea sencillo
es que estos dos capacitores están
conectados directamente en las
terminales de la batería es decir el
lado positivo del capacitor de 6 france
y el lado positivo del capacitor de 3
farage se encuentran conectados
directamente a la terminal positiva de
la batería y el lado izquierdo tanto del
capacitor de 6 farah como del capacitor
de 3 baratas se encuentran conectados
directamente a la terminal negativa de
la batería esto quiere decir que el
voltaje a través del capacitor de 6
farage va a ser el mismo que el voltaje
a través del capacitor de 3 farah que en
este caso es de 8 volts
mismo se cumple para el capacitor de
tres faros en donde el voltaje a través
de este capacitor de tres fuera también
es de 8 volts
de hecho la forma en la que están
conectados estos capacitores es como si
estuvieran cada uno por separado
conectados a la batería ya que ambos
experimentan la misma cantidad de
voltaje de la batería y ahora que
conocemos el voltaje en ambos
capacitores podemos usar la fórmula de
la capacitancia para encontrar la carga
en cada uno de ellos para el capacitor
de 3 fax así como el voltaje que en este
caso es el de la batería y nos queda que
la carga almacenada en este capacitor de
3 farah es de 24 kilos y podemos
realizar el mismo cálculo para el
capacitor de 6 varas ponemos su
capacitancia 6 france y el voltaje que
es de 8 volts y en este caso nos da que
la carga que se almacena en este
capacitor es de 48 colomos
y pueden ver que ya lo habíamos dicho la
carga en el capacitor de 6 farat es el
doble que la carga en el capacitor de 3
france a los capacitores que están
conectados de esta manera se les conoce
como capacitores en paralelo y ustedes
saben que dos capacitores están
conectados en paralelo si sus terminales
positivas están conectadas mutuamente y
que también sus terminales negativas
están conectadas mutuamente a través de
un alambre y ahora nos podemos preguntar
cuál será el valor de un solo capacitor
cuyo efecto en ese circuito será el
mismo que el de los dos capacitores
anteriores para encontrar la
capacitancia equivalente de capacitores
que están conectados en paralelo todo lo
que tenemos que hacer es sumar las
capacitancia individuales y la razón es
que si vemos todos estos capacitores
todas sus terminales positivas están
conectadas entre sí de manera que
podríamos combinar todos estos lados
positivos juntos y así formar un lado
positivo más grande
y ya que todos los lados negativos están
conectados entre sí por un alambre
podemos hacer lo mismo
combinar todos estos lados negativos
para hacer uno solo pero más grande así
que lo que hacemos cuando conectamos
capacitores en paralelo es crear un
capacitor más grande usando varios
capacitores más pequeños
ahora tengan en mente que la
capacitancia de un capacitor es
proporcional al área de las placas del
capacitor y ya que estamos usando las
áreas de cada uno de los capacitores en
conjunto para encontrar la capacitancia
total lo único que tenemos que hacer es
sumar las capacitancia individuales y
aun cuando la carga en cada uno de los
capacitores individuales no sea la misma
la suma de su carga va a dar igual a la
carga total la cual sería almacenada en
un capacitor equivalente si esos
capacitores individuales almacenarán un
coloma dos colones y tres colones cada
uno por separado su capacitor
equivalente almacenaría 6 q lo que es la
suma de todos los anteriores ahora
tratemos de aplicar estas ideas al
circuito que vimos al inicio la
capacitancia equivalente de este
capacitor de 6 farah y el capacitor de 3
parados sería el de un solo capacitor de
9 farat y ahora despejemos la cantidad
de carga que éste
de 9 horas podría almacenar al
conectarse a esta batería de 8 volts
usamos la definición de capacitancia y
encontramos que la carga en un capacitor
de 9 farage será de 72 colones y esto
tiene sentido ya que si recordamos lo
que pueden almacenar de carga estos 2
capacitores la carga en el capacitor de
6 farah era de 48 kilos y la carga en el
capacitor de 3 farage era de 24 kilos
sumamos 48 24 y nos queda 72 así que la
capacidad de carga con el capacitor de 6
faltas y el capacitor de 3 farage es de
72 colores la cual es la misma carga que
es un capacitor equivalente de 9 farat
va a guardar ahora veamos un problema un
poquito más complicado digamos que ahora
tenemos además un capacitor de 27 farah
cuando conectemos este circuito a la
batería cada uno de los capacitores va a
tener cierta cantidad de carga
almacenada vamos a tratar de encontrar
la carga
y el voltaje a través de cada uno de
estos capacitores bueno de entrada
podemos ver que el capacitor de 6 farts
y el de 3 farat se encuentran conectados
en paralelo lo que significa que ambos
deben tener el mismo voltaje pero en
este caso la magnitud de ese voltaje no
va a ser el de todo el voltaje de la
batería ya que aunque todas las
terminales negativas estén conectadas
entre sí y se encuentren directamente
conectadas a la terminal negativa de la
batería sus lados positivos no están
conectados a la terminal positiva de la
batería ya que en medio tenemos a este
capacitor de 27 frax de manera similar
el voltaje a través del capacitor de 27
farat no será el mismo que el del
voltaje de la batería ya que aunque el
lado positivo de este capacitor esté
conectado a la terminal positiva de la
batería su lado negativo no está
conectado a la batería se encuentre con
estos dos capacitores en su lugar
en resumen resulta que no conocemos el
voltaje en cada uno de estos capacitores
y si no conocemos el voltaje en cada uno
de estos capacitores individuales pues
no vamos a poder encontrar su carga lo
único que sabemos es que el voltaje a
través de todo este circuito es de 8
volts simplemente no conocemos los
voltajes individuales que pasan a través
de cada uno de estos capacitores así que
lo que vamos a hacer es reemplazar cada
uno de estos capacitores individuales
con un solo capacitor equivalente para
hacerlo comencemos con los capacitores
de 6 farage y de 3 farts ya que sabemos
que ambos se encuentran conectados en
paralelo y sabemos que están en paralelo
porque los datos positivos de ambos
capacitores se encuentran conectados
entre sí y lo mismo los lados negativos
de ambos capacitores están conectados
entre sí y usando la regla para combinar
los capacitores en paralelo nos
encontramos que la capacitancia
equivalente de los capacitores de 3
baratos y 6 varas
un solo capacitor de 9 para ti así que
ahora tenemos un solo capacitor de 9
para está conectado en serie a otro
capacitor de 27 fax y estos dos están
conectados en serie ya que están
conectados uno atrás de otro o en otras
palabras el lado positivo de uno de los
capacitores está conectado al lado
negativo del otro capacitor podemos
reemplazar estos dos capacitores con un
solo capacitor equivalente al usar la
fórmula para sumar capacitores
conectados en serie que es el inverso de
la capacitancia equivalente igual a el
inverso de la primera capacitancia más
el inverso de la segunda capacitancia si
sustituimos los valores de nuestros
capacitores aquí del ejemplo nos queda
que el inverso de la capacitancia
equivalente es de 0.1 48 148 y no
olviden calcular el inverso de este
número para encontrar la capacitancia
equivalente que va a ser de 6.75 farage
y ahora podemos reemplazar el capacitor
de 9 barac y el capacitor de 27 fuera
con un solo capacitor de 6.75 france y
ahora si podemos calcular la carga en
este capacitor de 6.75 barato ya que su
lado positivo se encuentra conectado a
la terminal positiva de la batería y su
lado negativo está conectado a la
terminal negativa de la batería por lo
que sabemos que el voltaje a través de
este capacitor va a ser de 8 volts y
usando la fórmula de capacitancia
podemos encontrar que su carga va a ser
para este capacitor de 6.75 para su
carga base de 54 kilos y ya que este fue
el capacitor equivalente para dos
capacitores en serie estos dos
capacitores en conjunto van a tener la
misma carga así que tanto el capacitor
de 27 farage como el capacitor de 9
farage van a tener la carga de 54 kilos
y en este punto ya podemos calcular el
voltaje que pasa a través de cada uno de
ellos
de nuevo usamos la definición de
capacitancia y si usamos 27 para 254
colones vamos a encontrar que el voltaje
a través de este capacitor es de 2 volts
hacemos los mismos cálculos para el
capacitor de 9 faros y encontramos que
el voltaje que pasa a través de este
capacitor es de 6 volts noten que 2
volts +6 volts nos dan 8 volts que es el
mismo voltaje de la batería y ahora
podemos encontrar la carga almacenada en
los capacitores individuales de 6
baratas y de 3 farat que teníamos
conectados en paralelo ahora sabemos que
el voltaje que pasa a través de estos
dos capacitores es de 6 volts ya que el
voltaje a través de cada capacitor
individual cuando están conectados en
paralelo será el mismo que el voltaje a
través de su capacitor equivalente y
ahora que conocemos el voltaje podemos
calcular su carga de nuevo usamos la
definición de capacitancia y para el
capacitor de 3 france nos encontramos
que su carga es de 18 kilos
hacemos los mismos cálculos para el
capacitor de seis partes y nos
encontramos que su carga es de 36 kilos
lo que tiene sentido ya que a 18 kilos
36 curl oms nos dan 54 kilos que da la
carga almacenada en el capacitor
equivalente de 9 baratas